kevin
how good is this flavor and i said it's
fantastic i worked with the cats i know
they love it and he said
no
you're gonna eat some right now prove it
he made me eat the whole tin
in front of the entire sales group
i want to talk about your parents
separately and we'll start with your dad
as alcoholism ultimately caused your
parents to
divorce and he died when you were seven
years old can you tell us what that was
like and how his alcoholism and his
death at a young age for you influenced
your childhood and your future
yeah it was it it's an unfortunate
situation um my mother uh
is a descendant from a lebanese family
and my father was irish and he was a
uh you know gregarious salesman and uh
they met in uh my grandfather's company
called kitty's talks and it was
unfortunate that that he was
you know a difficult man to live with
obviously alcoholism has its issues
i think he loved his kids i you know i
believe that but they ultimately uh
separated
and while he was alive and i think he
was very lonely at that point and he
died at a very young age at 37 years old
so that was very traumatic obviously my
mother was trying to
you know retain custody
and she in fact had to go to europe with
us to leave the country and we traveled
around europe for almost a year
going through the legal process of
separation
which was an extraordinary experience
for me i mean i went to all those
countries at a young age and
ultimately she remarried um
a man who who basically fathered me for
the rest of my life he's still alive
they ultimately settled in geneva
switzerland
and but during the journey my dad was
my stepfather george
became a member of the international
labor organization the ilo and he was an
expert in infrastructure
and so the ilo would go do projects in
multiple countries and he'd get two year
stints in each one so i've lived in
cyprus cambodia tunisia ethiopia
japan germany
switzerland france you name it i've been
there and
went through all those different
educational experiences in different
schools
i met some extraordinary people i met
paul pott i met haley selassie i met
seanuk i met them all and because they
were part of the international community
and so we you know the expats would
often uh you know mingle with the
government quite often and so that was
it was a really incredible experience
for me
that i didn't realize was happening
at the time i thought everybody lived
that way and that's what you do when
you're a child you assume that
everybody's growing up the same way but
in you know looking back it really
formed
uh how i think about investing how i
think about other people how i think
about other cultures
and indeed the way i invest and travel
today let's talk about your mom
georgette she was a small business owner
she came from a family of merchants
what kind of values did she teach you
and how do they affect your future she
believed in personal financial
independence
she really really believed that because
she
felt helpless
uh during the divorce period and and
that
really changed her view of of the way
she was going to manage her life and her
own money and her own destiny um and her
own investing and she became
you know great teacher to me about how
important it is to take care of yourself
and make sure
that you're safe and that you can then
take care of others around you and
she became sort of the matriarch of her
sisters and indeed the whole family she
she was a very pragmatic disciplined
woman about money
she was she was very very
liberal in her thinking which is
completely different than i am
and yet
she she was a great matriarch so
politically we didn't agree on anything
but around business and family values
she was very strong in that respect
and she always believed in charity and
she had a great idea of karma and she'd
always say look
two things if if you talk about money
and you brag about money one day you
won't have any money and also you have
to give back if you're successful
karma will get you if you don't give
back and i've lived by those
that those mantras uh as she taught them
to me when i was a teenager
she also taught you about the value of
saving let's talk about that
in food and exercising at a young age
she really believed that
you need balance in your life that you
really have to figure out how to live
well
take care of yourself she believed in
taking 20 percent
of her income and investing it
you know the idea of putting something
aside and only spending within your
means of of your income as the executor
i dispersed the money to to
extended family members and it's still
around i mean my goodness
what a lesson that was for me and it was
after her passing she taught me
something in death the lesson there is
the value of compounding and i think
it's important for our younger and even
the older uh listeners and viewers to
note
you don't have to be wealthy to save
and if you save and your money compounds
over the long term that is the key
compounding is the key
to financial freedom
yeah i totally agree with that i mean
it's geometric growth of wealth that's
what's going on there what were you like
as a kid were you popular were you a
leader and what did you do for fun i had
a different childhood because i was in a
different country every 24 months
and so i'd have to remake friends um i
you know it was it was
and some of these people that i met in
those years are some of my closest
friends today from multiple countries
but
we would roll into town didn't know
anybody um
you know find a place to live in places
like addis ababa ethiopia
and in addis ababa um
you know we were in an expat community
lots of different people from different
countries living there servicing the
united nations or the military or
whatever
and that for an example there there were
no bicycles we rode horses we rode
horses in the open plains of of uh
of ethiopia and and
uh you know i just thought that was
normal and that
and it was incredible i remember the
first time i ever
uh put a
barbecue out when we arrived there and
i remember it specifically it was it was
december of 1969.
i remember that because the white
beatles album had come out and i
received that for christmas that year
and i was
you know i went outside and lit up the
fire and and uh put put a couple of
hamburgers out
and when in about five minutes the sky
blackened with giant vultures circling
massive birds prehistoric looking you
know shuttering the sun for me and those
are the kind of images i remember from
of extraordinary outcomes of you know
living in countries like that you do not
barbecue in addis ababa because there
are really really big vultures hanging
around
and they when they smell that meat
they come and get it that was the nature
of
of living as an expat in all these
countries
is it necessary to get a formal
education there's enough
to go through the school of hard knocks
well i'm getting a lot of trouble
talking about this
because you know when i finish with you
here today i'm going to harvard to teach
my class and i'm a guest lecturer there
to graduating cohorts
and i tell them
i don't remember
anything
from my education
i don't remember
any of the lessons in
in finance or anything from my mba none
of it
it went in one ear and out the other
but i still know that cohort of people
and they have assisted me in my
businesses all around the world because
they're the leader of banks or they're
running industries or they're running
companies
the secret to education is not the
education
it's the people you meet
on the journey
now obviously professors don't like to
hear that
but it's the truth
and that's why you do it that's why you
try
and go to college if you can
to meet those people so all of these
paths and doors open for you that
wouldn't had you not had that
opportunity
between your first and second years of
your
mba program you worked at nabisco and
after you graduated they hired you as a
print as a brand manager in their cat
food brand can you share with us how
this experience and what you learned
there
about beef paste and tuna paste
contributed to your later success at the
learning company and in your career
yeah as part of your mba in the summer
you have to take an internship that's
part of your education
and so i chose nabisco brands
um because i was interested in marketing
and the day i arrived
the brand manager there who was dutch
a really interesting guy he said to me
i'm going to take you to the rendering
plant
where we make
cat food
the bed the brand was called miss mew
and my job for those 90 days was to
design a new flavor and get it on the
shelf
so the whole idea of cat food is um the
more facings the more market share you
get
the more flavors you have on the shelf
that are maintained by the grocers
and so
when i got to the rendering plant there
was basically two production lines
one was was taking um you know the faces
of cattle and chicken faces and and uh
renderings and certain fat off organs i
mean it was just brutal and then sea of
the sea of
japan underbelly tuna
that is not sold in premium markets is
what makes all of the fish flavors of
most cat foods what he explained to me
was look
human beings like to open a can of cat
food
and have it very
stiff so they can turn the can over and
drop it into the food plate and it keeps
its round shape but cats
like liquid they want a soup
we've tried to sell soup
for the cats but the people won't buy it
they think they're getting ripped off
so you have to find a balance of making
it
moist enough so the cat will eat it
versus the person that wants to just
have a puck there
and we had a plant that had over 500
cats in upstate new york that we would
sample all these things what he was
trying to tell me was
you only need two engines you need the
chicken
beef mixture and you need
the tuna fish and everything else you
just dream up
and that's what i did and i remember you
know at the end of the session just
before i went back for second year of
mba i i had to
go to the head sales
meeting
hundreds of sales reps
and um i learned by fire how that worked
i said guys i you know in order for me
to get a good mark on this you got to
get this sold into every grocery store
in north america
and the head of sales got up and you
know in the summer back in the room said
kevin
how good is this flavor and i said it's
fantastic
i work with the cats i know they love it
and he said
no
you're going to eat some right now prove
it
he made me eat the whole tin
in front of the entire sales group
and later i found out that was
what they did to every intern every year
i didn't realize at the time not the
eating in front of the sales force but
what what the
the head dutch guy taught me about the
two engines
because that changed
my entire life
it's so amazing the lessons you learn
that you store in your memory and they
bring them back later
to apply them in a different way
that becomes very powerful you started
softkey in a toronto basement a garage a
basement that's where a lot of companies
get going
with two partners the company was a
publisher and distributor of personal
computer software
for windows and macintosh computers
which like it is now
was a very crowded field with many
competitors doing very similar things
what on earth did you know about
computers at that time and what was the
aha moment where you said yourself
there's a need in the market and i want
to fill it in those days when you when
you had to when you were doing film and
you needed the title of let's say you
know a hockey player or something
you had to
actually create the font
and burn it into the film
and i had met a man named john freeman
he had taken a hewlett-packard
single pen plotter a device that drove a
pen in an x and y
angle
and he wrote some software
to to actually
write fonts
to to write letters and i met him in the
basement of what was called the osborne
computer club i bought an osborne
computer which was cpm computer the
first part of the computer ever and he
showed me
the software and i said john
that's incredible that's going to change
the world for a lot of people because
you're allowing to do charts and bars
and graphs with letters and everything
else why don't we form a partnership why
don't why don't we go 50 50 i'll be the
marketing guy you'll be the programmer
and i'll go sell this software to every
single plotter manufacturer all around
the world in japan in the us germany you
name it that's exactly what we did i
went to a woman named mary zoller
who at the time was the brand manager
for hewlett-packard all plotters in san
diego
and i met with her and said mary
why don't you just give me 10 cents
a copy
and put this in every single plotter and
she said kevin very interesting idea
but i'm the top of the pecking order
i can do that anytime i want why don't
you sell it to somebody else that was
one of my competitors first and she
pointed me in the direction of a couple
of japanese manufacturers i went to see
them next
and they said yes
and from no sales at all
we started getting checks for millions
of dollars because we were selling it at
10 20 30 cents a copy
for millions of of plotters and that was
the beginning of soft keys software
products
um
and that eventually became the learning
company that started in my basement and
i was i was traveling all around the
world it was just the two of us in the
beginning and then of course it was
thousands of employees later on but it
was the idea of oem bundling it was the
idea that of marrying the software with
the firmware with the plotter that was
the success of softkey software and then
of course we became the largest
educational software company in the
world the largest reference company in
the world we did compton's encyclopedia
before wikipedia we did all that stuff
and and i never never forgot the lesson
because i said to my board of directors
i told them the story
of the cat food
my thesis was this let's buy everybody
in because in educational software
there's basically two directions that
you're trying to go
math and reading scores you're trying to
advance math and reading scores at
children between four
and eight years old because that's how
they get through high school that's how
they get to college it's all math and
reading score still is today
and i said guys let's buy every brand
and let's just do two engines one for
math one for reading
and we'll fire everybody else we don't
need all that overhead we'll just have
two and then we'll add characters like
big bird and we'll add characters like
barbie and we'll add characters like
reader rabbit on top of just like you
added the bacon bits to the
the beef patty in the in the cat food
thing because the kids don't buy the
software the parents do i mean our cost
of capital
went down because our profits went up
our stock price went up our access to
both debt and equity at much higher
prices reduced our cost of capital and
we started buying everybody we we
acquired the entire industry and became
the largest educational software company
in the world until motel bought us
because we were actually encroaching on
the toy companies too i owe it all you
know to two people one was the woman who
fired me from a goose ice cream parlor
and the other was that dutch product
manager who taught me about engines
that's what it boils down to you took
the learning company name
uh when you bought it for 606 million
dollars when that deal closed you moved
the company to cambridge massachusetts
home of akamai technologies
and then six years after that took six
years of mattel value for 4.2 billion
dollars
i mean that's a monster deal
a massive home run but it was soon
called one of the most disastrous
acquisitions of its time what happened
there can you take us through it from
starting a company to growing it to all
of its challenges and all the successes
to the massive sale and then what
happened
after the sale and can you tell us
how you bounced back from that that
could not have been fun
no in fact um
what what what happened was this the the
thesis of the merger or the acquisition
if you want to call it mattel is going
to buy us
and then we would take their their big
brands like barbie for example and put
it into the math and and the reading
engines and the same with american girl
and we had demand for those products by
the millions of units and so
when when i got there um
i immediately moved to uh to la to start
working with the product managers to get
these projects out because we'd already
pre-sold them to walmart and target and
some of the big distributors all around
the world
and my assumption was as we always could
get out a product we could do it in four
months because we already had the engine
we just needed the graphics design and
of the of the the doll or whatever it
was going to be so i explained that to
the management at um at mattel and i
said look here's the path here's the
order size here's what's going to happen
here's the trajectory here's the target
sales
two years later we still hadn't released
barbie
teaches math or barbie helps you read or
teach us typing or anything
the culture was so different it was so
not entrepreneur entrepreneurial a toy
company that's been around for a hundred
years does not move quickly they had a
whole procedure in terms of how to
integrate it and checks and balances on
the brand and everything else
and it was extremely frustrating for me
because we you know we were trying to
harness the entrepreneurial spirit in a
very large corporation which was
impossible it was a pretty big lesson
and you know in retrospect that was a
huge mistake because you know we should
have recognized that it wasn't going to
it wasn't going to work and and worse
there was huge conflict between myself
and the board of mattel because i was
for a while the largest shareholder they
had personally i own more stock than
most the board members did and i just
said guys this isn't working and as a
shareholder i'm i'm unhappy we've got to
fix this and and i know how to fix it so
get out of the way and let me do it
otherwise we're going to lose a lot of
value here
that's not what they did they fought a
tooth and nail and that was a it was a
you know important lesson for me
culture matters in a business
and if you're going to sell your company
don't stick around afterwards start a
new one you never do it twice i mean
i'll never do what that would happen
there again because i know to avoid that
that's the whole idea of experience
that you wouldn't have seen coming but
yes it was challenging no question about
it and
uh later in later years in fact just a
few weeks ago i had um
i had lunch with alec gore who's a very
famous private equity one of the big
spac operators and that's where he and i
met years and years ago because he
bought some of the assets what i
eventually tried to do was buy back the
learning company from mattel
and they wouldn't sell it to me they
sold to alec instead but we've become
great friends since then you've said
that business is war and that you want
to kill your competitors and you want
them to fear you
that you want to make their lives
miserable and you want to steal market
share you want everybody in your team to
think you're going to win is business
really war
it is and if you think it isn't you'll
be one of the people that loses
it's competition for the best ideas the
brightest people
the most market share the most markets
the most innovative products it's always
war when you get out there if you don't
understand that you are marching to the
orders of your shareholders your
employees and your customers and you
have to win
you won't win now i have nothing wrong
with
mission driven businesses if you want to
give a dollar away every time you sell a
product or plant a tree i get it and
that in fact is a good strategy because
a lot of people care about that or
eliminate plastic waste which i'm a big
believer in from my environmental days
but the whole idea is that you have to
set some parameters that you have to
achieve
and you've got to get the whole team
following in that direction if anybody
is not agreeing on that direction get
rid of them
they're destroying your culture
everybody has to agree and i what i
would do with my management is always
say look here's the plan for the next
quarter does anybody have an issue with
it is there anything you don't like
about this plan is there something you
want to change in this plan speak your
mind now or forever be at peace because
we're going to go achieve this plan i
don't care how how hard we have to work
to get there how many hours we have to
work or where you have to go to to make
it happen we're going to achieve this
plan because we're going to turn around
and tell the street this is what we're
going to do and shareholders are going
to listen and we're going to do it and
and i think that is business that that
really matters now
you may not agree with me um i don't
know any other way to do it
you need to motivate people they have to
believe in your leadership they have to
want to follow you and if they don't
you've got to help them find someone
else to follow
that's your job and i would always give
great severance packages to people that
didn't want to get on board i just got
rid of them and everybody that worked
with me understood the challenges we had
and faced it and we worked together to
make it work and we all did well
together that was the whole idea if you
like that video wait you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe